I think that's it that that NGOs human
rights ngos have done a an effective job
at putting pressure on Beijing over the
Tibet situation and I think that it has
paid some dividends in these talks that
are now on going with with the Dalai
Lama some people say they're a sham some
people say they might you know they
might result in something I don't think
that the United States ought to boycott
I think there's maybe the possibility
that that the president could not attend
the opening ceremonies but that that's
something you should decide a few months
from now to see what happens with these
talks I think if they are genuine and
trying to make some sort of a difference
which most people say they aren't but
that that we ought to acknowledge if
they or at least made an effort but
ultimately we don't want to isolate
China ultimately we want China to step
up to the plate and be a responsible
player in the global system and that is
a harder challenge for the United States
than worrying about their aggression so
getting them to actually pay for some of
the public goods that the United States
has been providing actually getting them
to take responsibility and ownership
that's the bigger challenge
I mean I think we ought to you know we
ought to be aware of it but the fact is
that that their trade with Africa is
absolutely dwarfed by united states
trade with africa i do think that the
United States ought to engage
diplomatically with Africa in a way that
we haven't in many years I mean China is
actually paying attention to Africa it
had all African heads of state come to
visit Beijing which is something we've
never done and so and they are building
schools and roads and all that and that
part of what they're doing is great the
problem is that they are also embolden
assump ritty horrible regimes there and
I think we we and more importantly we
combine with other powers like the
European Union and Japan ought to be
trying to convey to China why we have
the rules in place that we do that that
for example try that thai loans to
getting rid of corruption I think China
is really on a learning curve here and I
think that they will ultimately go along
with well let me see I think that they
will ultimately learn that giving money
with no strings attached could backfire
at the end of the day but I'm not
worried about I'm not worried at all
about China taking Africa away from the
United States
I think for the average individual in
China life is a lot freer than it then
it used to be certainly that most
average citizens can work where they
choose they can live where they choose
they can say privately what they choose
they can travel more or less freely and
that's very different from the China of
30 years ago and a lot there there's a
lot more people now join the middle
class in China there's some 300 400
million people who've been lifted out of
poverty and you know you talk to Chinese
about human rights and they think well
you know you and the West don't
understand that having something to eat
is a human right and that's what we
really care about so you'll get that
kind of reaction in China very
sophisticated about that the fact is
that most most Chinese people using the
internet are not trying to find
information about democracy they mean
they're they're you know they're
chatting with their friends and their
you know checking sports scores and
stock quotes and all that and the the
big sites that that people visit that
Chinese people visit in China are pretty
tied to the government so they are
reliant on the government to be able to
continue to function and so they do a
lot of self-censorship and that's
basically how it works but if you look
at the various protests that are that
have been organized around China a lot
of that is done through text messages
and through the internet so it's really
a tool that is very hard to completely
control I mean if any one person in
China absolutely wants to find out
information about Tibet they can they
can do that through various technical
means of getting around the blocks but
overall the Chinese government does a
very good job of censoring
that china is not a unified monolith
that that China itself does not know
what its trajectory is that they are
ultimately very pragmatic and that if we
apply pressure in the right way
especially working with other countries
to apply pressure that we can actually
move them forward in a constructive way
and that seeing them as an enemy is only
it will only perpetuate the possibility
that they could become that enemy and
that in fact on a lot of issues they
really are our partners and we got to
see it in that way I think on the things
that I think that first hundred days
will provide an opportunity to do some
symbolic things that will indicate to
the world that we've been on the wrong
course and we want to now join the world
community again so for example closing
Guantanamo Bay making a real commitment
on climate change saying something about
the future of Iraq and how it will
eventually come to an end re-engaging on
Middle East peace I mean I think those
are some pretty key items and they're
many more but those are some pretty key
items that I think will immediately
signal to the world that we are we are
on a different course now and I think
that's important in terms of who he or
she should visit or talk to I would say
i mean the pivotal powers as we call
them all all the heads of all those
states would be pretty important so
China Russia Europe Japan and India for
example I think they would be a top of
the list
this way um i think obama does have a
different vision for for u.s. foreign
policy i think he is of a different
generation and i do think that he is
wants to lead the world in a positive
direction and that's what that's what
his constant theme has been and that
he's willing to talk with with regimes
that we might not like and that's our
reality we might not like the Chinese we
might not like the Russians but the fact
is we have to work with them in order to
in order to really secure America's
safety and prosperity here at home we
want to open the debate about how the
United States is going to proceed in a
world that's just very different
geopolitically that were there these
more stronger players on the scene and
we want to suggest that the way to do
that is by not fearing their power but
leveraging their power and we want
Americans to think about that it's
actually a very optimistic message I
think America is you know we're going
through really tough economic times now
and there's a lot of doom and gloom
about America's future but it's very
bright we have a really diverse creative
population we've come back from far
worst crises in the past and if we can
just lead in a new way and if we can
take care of our some of our problems at
home you know we're gonna do just fine
people has been interested in foreign
policy I think I'm you know first
generation on one side and second
generation on the other so and I
traveled a bit when I was a kid and so I
think it's I'm lucky to be one of
probably fairly few Americans who from a
young age was exposed to the rest of the
world and i think i had a hope for for
Americans in general would be that they
you know get to travel more and see that
there's you know it's a big world out
there but these are these are really
critical issues and you know I've been
working in foreign policy a long time
and and I think we are on the cusp of a
real of a new era and I just want
America to see that I don't think it
directly changed our policy stances but
it did it does make you aware of the
next generation when you have your own
kids and what kind of world you're going
to be leaving them and and so I think in
that sense it made you probably look
forward more than more than I typically
have there's actually fun it's you know
you keep each other on track you know
when you have someone else that you you
know you have to give a chapter to it's
easier to stay on deadline and I just
find it much more fun to work
collaboratively than to be cooped up in
my house my own research and writing
changed and evolved and it wasn't it
didn't stay consistent but we would we
would write different chapters than we
would swap and then you know critique
each other's and we agreed we agreed on
a basic outline of the entire book
upfront and then and then sometimes you
know our edit or throw out of chapter
and then we would you know we would
write chapters together so it kind of it
evolved and changed but you know she's
in New York and I was in LA so there's a
lot of you know email and then we would
meet from time to time different if
that's where we were